foreign
okay
ask a question
angels are creatures of dust we discover
that through Mary Malone an Oxford
scholar and his dust Dark Matter yes
but what are you
angels
angels exist across worlds a coalescence
of dust into Ascension active being
don't be afraid
we're not going to hurt you
what are you Benny a Lim
angels in your language in
they have very human characteristics
they fall in love balthamus and Baruch
for example are a very strong
romantically linked couple the bond
between balthamos and Baruch is very
strong and where one goes the other
feels
they are sometimes known as the Watchers
in that they watch over certain worlds
making
stimulating guiding but why
vengeance
they have long ago been thrown out of
the Kingdom of Heaven through rebelling
against the rule of the authority we who
fought for truth were cast out of the
Kingdom Savannah is the leader of the
Rebel ninja she has been leading the
rebel angels for Millennia and joins
forces with me the great betrayer
the kingdom as we know it has already
gone a labus
this is our final Rebellion it's a
difficult relationship because angels
and humans are so far away from each
other in terms of their perspective on
life if I have to incarcerate every
angel I will if I have to take a knife
to the heart of the authority himself I
will
[Music]
please
foreign
I intend to March upon the kingdom of
heaven and I should very much like you
to join me
asriel is a revolutionary and freedom
fighter
he finds his allies and begins building
the base for the Rebellion
welcome to the Republic of Heaven
Commander the real war is coming
and we must win it asriel's Republic is
a military encampment for science
Ingenuity and his military forces to
gather astral's council is made up of
Commander or gunway who looks after all
operational matters Brutus guardi brings
plans of the witches it's a fania the
light Angel equivalent of metatron's
dark angel the great betrayer you speak
of betrayal
when you have taken orders to kill one
of our own kind
not Ezreal
broke and Commander Rogue the leader of
the galavespians and the whole of the
Spy Network what is it a message from
our magisteriums by agent salmakia she
says they're preparing to undertake a
search mission
your daughter they think she's the most
important child that's ever lived
asriel's end goal is to fight the
authority and what he learns because
that it's a slightly different kind of
fight what is this it's kind of best
being communication device we have a
message from that agent in the
magisterium we're about to learn on that
island in the German ocean I'll take the
intention craft it's the fastest way
understood
try not to die
why are you following us I am a member
of Lord azrael's Republic I'm here for
you and the girl
and your knife
the galavastians are very very small
creatures who asriel uses as his spy
Network
not asriel your daughter sir sarmakia
believes she's in danger when is Lyra
not in danger commands are rogue is the
galavastian who sits on asriel's Council
he has galavespian's positioned all over
the world and they communicate with them
and give him information agent Sal
macchia for example is positioned in the
headquarters of the magisterium so she
can toll wrote what the magisterium are
up to retrieve the child
retrieve the mother
and return them to me
Dead or Alive
they communicate using this really
strange device called the lone stone
resonator which means that they can
communicate across the world
Stone resonating go ahead we're about to
land a remote island in the German ocean
agency get to the children get them to
safety then stay with them until I
arrive understood understood they're
quite prickly you've been lying this
whole time
the knife is broken stop attacking him
give me one reason why I should but
quite honorable as well because Ezreal
needs him safe
whatever you're doing do it quickly
this war will need us all
we're about to land a remote island in
the German ocean Fair Isle I know the
place I'll take the intention crowd
the intention craft is a machine that
through the intent of his mind will
allow Azrael to journey through
different worlds the craft may not be
ready for this well then that is on the
pair of us is it not
the force between himself and his demon
powers the intentional craft
so your demon powers it and your
intentions control it am I right
I don't think he'd want you to be
looking at them quite so forensically
Mrs Coulter looks over some plans for it
and we see her exploring it before
Azrael arrives and then we just see her
having the sort of clockiness to get in
it and just give it a go
[Music]
goodbye Israel
[Music]